when you first got traded to Toronto  what went through your mind was that one  of your preferred destinations and how  did your feelings evolve or change  during this run and how do you feel now  I mean we all know where my destinations  were but obviously you know like I said  when I was there on my opening day  meeting that uh you know I was focused  on now and you know I wanted to make  history here and that's all I did I just  you know I'm still playing basketball no  matter what Jersey I have on and the  guys here been you know making Rennes in  the playoffs before I came so I know  they were talented team and you know I  just came in with the right mindset  let's go out and win ballgames at exile  probably a day later or the day that I  got traded and told him let's go out and  do some special no little your best  friend left I know you're mad but uh you  know let's make this thing work out and  we were here today